[Music]
greetings
it's february now and you know what
month that is love is
in the air and while we probably can't
be with our loved ones physically at
this time of year
fret not vinnie tube's here to bring you
our very special
list for the day because when you're an
anime character you just find it hard to
stick to one come on don't tell me
you've only got one
waifu or husbando out there not when
there are some characters that can
relate with your dilemma
today i'll be counting down my top 10
favorite harem anime there's a lot of
them
but these are the ones that i think you
should really check out while you're
making a guess as to which title will
top the list
make sure to hit that subscribe button
and help grow the channel
[Music]
we start off with a recent contender
rent a girlfriend
still fresh on everyone's mind is this
rom-com starring happy-go-lucky kazuya
unfortunately his happy days come to an
end when his girlfriend dumps him angry
at the outcome
he decides to strike back at the world
by using an app to rent his replacement
girlfriend when said rental girlfriend
turns out to be chizuru
event flags get triggered which include
a couple squabble
a collapsed grandmother and lots and
lots of misunderstandings
all this culminating kazuya declaring
chizuru to be his legitimate girlfriend
finding themselves in a whole new web of
misunderstandings just how long can they
keep
up this facade of being in a
relationship fake relationships
misunderstandings and heaps and heaps of
comedy make rent a girlfriend a fun
watch
the main character does have his share
of criticisms but i finally find the
girls enjoyable to follow and in the
harem anime
you know who the main attractions are
right
[Music]
in our 9th spot we have another comedy
series this time it's early 2010's hit
series
hagenai godanka being a transferee looks
to make good impressions and some
friends unfortunately for him his
expression and blonde hair gets him
labeled as a delinquent so now that plan
falls flat on his face even before it
begins
however as fate would have it he finds
someone just as big of a loner as he is
who spends her time talking to her
imaginary friend the duo then decided to
form the neighbours club a club tailor
made for people who have no friends and
a way for them to learn
social skills joining them are the cast
that you'd expect to find in harem
rom-com anime the popular daughter of
the school chairman
the trap the pervy freshman and much
much more will these social losers ban
to get their act together or will the
club just implode from the
eccentricities present lots of edgy
fun hijinks and comedy those are the
first things that would come into mind
when talking about this show haganai
does have its genuinely touching moments
in between those over-the-top antics and
i found myself thoroughly entertained
when i first watched it has it aged well
now into the new decade
well there's only one way to find out
and that's to watch it and it's second
season
[Music]
moving past the comedic school harems
temporarily we start moving on to the
supernatural ones and we start off with
to love rue
confessing is hard it really is it takes
a lot of guts to confess and that's just
something that paul rito yuki just can't
find despite being haplessly in love
with haruna rito just can't spit it out
but wait
it gets worse when one night the naked
lala devolu crashes into his bathtub you
see lala happens to be the princess of
an alien empire and she'd like nothing
more than to marry this guy in order to
avoid a political marriage
from then on things start to spiral out
of control with more and more girls
coming into the picture
making rito's confession to haruna
borderline impossible
full of slapstick humor and a healthy
dose of lewd moments tuna roo is a
winner for me you won't find a shortage
of sexy or cute girls in the show that's
helped to find the edgy genre in its
heyday i have to preface this and say
that the anime is quite episodic and
filler-ish but at the end of the day
it's mindless entertainment that counts
and i find the show very satisfying in
that regard
[Music]
up next is strike the blood in a world
ruled by
three almighty vampire progenitors there
exists a fourth one
a thing of legend a vampire so powerful
that he keeps the balance of the world
in check
now you wouldn't expect someone like him
to be an ordinary high school boy right
neither does kojo akatsuki but his
identity as the fourth progenitor does
attract a lot of unwanted attention much
to his shah grin fearing his
capabilities the lion king organization
sends a personal watchdog the apprentice
sword shaman yukina
however mishaps and their shared
awkwardness would bring the two together
into alliance and deep friendship that's
a good thing because they're gonna need
every bit of power to defend itogami
island against numerous supernatural
threats
meanwhile the duo also have to deal with
the suedes of girls that just seem to
gravitate towards kojo
a personal favorite of mine in the early
2000s strike the blood is your typical
simple and formulaic popcorn
entertainment show full of action and
echi
a lot of cool powers some genuinely
enjoyable character dynamics
and a plot with a surprising amount of
layers make the show a fun show to
unwind to
also notable is how the series is
currently in its fourth season and is
looking to be on pace for a near
completion adaptation something
remarkable for anime of this genre
next in line data live spirits
special beings that exist and bring
about disasters there are two ways to
deal with them
option number one eradicate them with
military force
option number two date them and make
them fall in love that spiel basically
tells you what you need to know about
this show
unlucky contender this time is shido who
gets forcibly recruited in the
organization ratatoskr
led by his sister kotori he learns that
he has the power to deal with the danger
posed by spirits
a really easy way that doesn't involve
any direct fighting
all he has to do is date the spirit make
her fall in love
and seal the deal with a kiss with such
a unique ability shido finds the fate of
the world resting on his shoulders and
it's all up to his romantic prowess to
save the day
cute girls supernatural powers and a bit
of fan service is a tried and tested
formula and data live is a testament to
that the premise might make it seem to
be one of those weird japanese series
however data live really went the extra
mile and actually came up with a rather
dark and serious plot that managed to
weave together
an unexpectedly deep lore and a lot of
twists it's really something genius that
only japan can come up with and that's
what makes this one one of my favorite
harems of all time
three seasons a movie and a spin-off or
out but with this series still
maintaining a decent amount of
popularity
i wouldn't be surprised to see this get
a full adaptation somewhere down the
line
[Music]
why not make it three in a row for
supernatural action-like novel harems
let's cap the chain off with a series
that's left its mark on the
genre high score dxd there are many
words to describe isse hyodo but the
most prominent and accurate of them
would be
probably pervert dreaming of one day
having a harem of his own things seem to
be looking up for him when he gets asked
out on a date by a beautiful girl
first aids never pan out just ask
garneki who likewise had to endure a
similar fate by issei
being killed by the girl on his very
first date luckily for him
riaz gremeri the school's prettiest girl
and a devil
finds him and revives him as her servant
while subsequently recruiting him into
the school's occult research club now in
his second life issei must learn to
fight and survive in the brutal world of
angels and devils where danger lurks in
every corner
oh and don't forget to mention the lewd
moments with new comrades too
while a lot of you would have known high
school dxd for the plot
or caps of course i'll come out and say
that it also has one hell of a
compelling plot you don't carve out a
legacy like the show has with only fan
service and i just find it amazing how
such an intriguing
story has been masterfully weaved
between the numerous risque moments high
school dxd
for most people is fan service
personified and the main attraction is
definitely the beautiful girls in the
ecchi but i would also
gladly vouch for its plot if you're up
for probably the perfect combination of
plot in caps and plot in small letters
come join the dxd train you won't be
[Music]
disappointed
next we take a look at the world god
only knows
kemar katsuragi is known as the god of
conquest
the famed personality who can conquer
any girl's heart
in visual novels in reality he wants
nothing to do with the world of romance
girls and all that sort of stuff
after all 2d is king and who needs
romantic partners when you can have
waifus who would never betray you right
thanks to his overconfidence he gets
roped into a brand new mission
with the demon elsie as his guide he
gets tasked with retrieving runaway
spirits who've escaped from hell
and want nothing but trouble only
problem is that he can only do that by
conquering the hearts of real girls
the actual unpredictable kind mind you
not computer data
now he must apply his skills from his
favorite visual novels as he's forced to
win the affection of numerous girls how
will the legendary god of conquest fare
once the predictability of video games
gets taken away
despite having a premise that's somewhat
similar with the previously featured
data live
the world god only knows executes its
plot in a very different manner
eschewing action and explosions in favor
of drama and comedy the world god only
knows provides its own fresh take on the
solve supernatural problems by romancing
the premise to provide
a very engaging watch
[Music]
our third place for this list is the
quintessential quintuplets
ace high school student futaro has it
rough he doesn't have a lot of friends
and he's sorely lacking in the financial
department however
a bright light shines at the end of the
tunnel the family dead and it comes in
the form of a tutoring job
imagine his surprise when his duty turns
out to be itsuki
a girl that's not on best terms with him
also itsuki doesn't come alone she's
revealed to be one of a quintuplet of
sisters
and fudaro's job is to tutor all five of
them helping all five of them graduate
despite their flanking grades is already
a herculean task and that's not even
getting to juggling their personalities
should i mention that all five of them
start falling for futaro for their own
reasons
looks like our hero might have just
bitten off more than he could chew
harems are
plenty in the world of anime especially
those involving schools and couples that
have so much friction between them but
for the quintessential quintuplets
something just clicks for me it's
probably the attractive characters
who come together and come out with some
special kind of chemistry
i just love the show for its character
interactions and dynamics and from there
it maneuvers its way to one of the more
interesting plots that you can expect
out of a harem title
it certainly got a rather divisive manga
ending but with this second season
airing let's see if the anime follows
suit
since we already talked about rent a
girlfriend how about the show that's
quite comparable in setting
nisakoi yakuza air raku ichijo has many
things on his mind
one of which is the promise he made 10
years ago to a childhood friend he
remembers little of the incident but he
does carry around a locked pendant which
can only be unlocked by the key held by
the promised girl
now a high schooler raku wants nothing
more than to have an ordinary life
tough luck for him when he encounters
kirisaki heir to the rival beehive gang
in order to prevent all hell from
breaking loose they decide to fake a
relationship despite their immense
differences and unmatching personalities
adding to the problem is the fact that
raku really has his eyes on his
classmate
kosaki onodera with more and more
mercurial elements in the form of girls
having a claim to be raku's promised
girl adding to the picture looks like
raku is going to have more than he can
handle
i think for many of you nisikoi needs
little introduction it's probably the
quintessential harem
rom-com of the 2010s that spawned
probably some of the biggest waifu wars
that i've ever laid witness to i could
never get tired of watching raku and the
gang as they go through one misadventure
after another
in the quest for finding true love
[Music]
topping off our list is secano a stroke
of inspiration
it can strike like a flash and sure as
hell is powerful
for otaku tamoya it comes in the form of
a fateful encounter with a girl
brimming with inspiration he recruits
legendary creators the artist iriri
sawamura spencer
and top student and big time author utah
wanting nothing more than to make the
best game starring the mysterious girl
unfortunately the gun of his dreams ends
up being the docile and plain and boring
megumikato
nevertheless tomoya is determined to
make his vision a success
no matter what stands in their way the
moyas group will stop at nothing to
create the greatest visual novel
featuring the greatest hero in ever
i play segano at the top of the list for
several reasons the show is just so
relatable for a big anime fan like me
and i really enjoyed watching the
interactions and the development among
the characters
it's a show that you probably aren't
supposed to take too seriously with its
etchy jokes
awkward moments and plethora of comedy
segments nonetheless i found the series
just chock full of touching scenes and
developments and it's one of the shows
that i can truly say
i got really immersed in if you're the
type who's into shows with otaku
references and lots of upbeat moments
sandwich between character drama then
don't pass this one up
now quit stalling and start watching the
series from the start to end with its
two seasons and the movie which caps off
the whole story
how's that for a selection of harem
titles to reach your quota of cute and
sexy this valentine's day
i've got a lot more harem shows that i'd
love to feature but alas i've only got
space for 10 haven't i with your support
i could consider making a second list so
go ahead and hit those like and
subscribe buttons normally i'd ask you
to write down your recommendations for
future titles or lists on the comments
section but for this video
let's try something different how about
this time sharing your favorite girl
from the featured shows on this list and
we can see who's the most popular one
out there let's play nice and show some
love this
valentine's season i hope you enjoyed
this video make sure to come back next
time for more anime goodness only
on vinnie tube
[Music]
you